avons décidé de consacrer notre second
débat débat de société volontairement
démarquez vous savez de l'actualité du
jour chiffre qui a été rendu public à la
fin du mois d'avril près de 86 mille
personnes qui exécute une peine
privative de liberté en france la france
qui se démarque des autres pays d'europe
la surpopulation carcérale est elle une
fatalité dans notre pays on en débat
dans une minute mais d'abord les
chiffres les détails tout de suite avec
sandra cercle
un chiffre qui ne cesse d'augmenter plus
de soixante et onze mille personnes sont
incarcérées dans les prisons françaises
au 1er avril soit une hausse de plus de
9% en un an à quoi s'ajoutent les plus
de 14000 personnes sous une peine de
détention à domicile sous surveillance
électronique
soit au total plus de 85 mille personnes
exécutant une peine privative de liberté
un record depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale conséquence les conditions de
détention des prisonniers se dégrade
toujours plus et les conditions de
travail des personnels pénitentiaires
aussi c'est beaucoup de travail pour le
personnel c'est plus de risques c'est
plus de conflits plus d'agressions et
forcément depuis un an et conscience est
monté après avoir vidé les prisons
pendant le coc vie d'aujourd'hui on
expose les chiffres j'étais sûr non à la
maison d'arrêt de nantes la semaine
dernière
imaginez bien que ça ne peut que rendre
difficile la gestion au quotidien des
personnels cette nouvelle hausse en 2022
du nombre de détenus en france tranche
avec la situation de nombreux autres
pays européens où le recours à
l'emprisonnement baisse c'est le cas aux
pays-bas où le travail d'intérêt général
se développe ou la mise en place de
jours amendes en allemagne si le
versement de l'âme on ne respecte pas
l'échéancier c'est l'incarcération
automatique le bracelet qui est sous
utilisé je pense moment en france là car
ces rations j'allais dire à la maison
quoi après là aussi il nous faut des
moyens il faut qu'on puisse nous faire
le travail les conseillers d'insertion
et probation faire le leur vous avez
dans certains services je pense à celui
de rennes en service de nuit vous avez
un agent qui surveille plus de 2500
bracelet électronique ce qui est
ingérable donc qu'il ya des aménagements
de peines qui sont possibles je pense
aussi qu'il faut retravailler sur on a
fermé beaucoup d'hôpitaux psychiatriques
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la france manque
d'hôpitaux psychiatriques on a des tas
de gens qui n'ont rien à faire en prison
dans la loi de la réforme de la justice
de 2019 sur les 7000 places promises
avant la fin du précédent quinquennat
seuls 2000 auraient été livrés
la surpopulation carcérale est elle une
fatalité française on en débat tout de
suite et je vous présente mes invités
zlin sire-marin bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes magistrate honoraire mme andreu la
ligue des droits de l'homme j'accueille
également françois noël buffet bonsoir
sénateurs l ère du rhône président de la
commission des lois ici au sénat mathieu
quinquis bonsoir soir que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris et membre de
l'observatoire international des prisons
matthieu croissandeau évidemment il
rester à mes côtés je redonne les
chiffres de base ceux qui ont finalement
motivé notre décision de consacrer ce
débat à la question de la surpopulation
carcérale ce chiffre 80 5772 personnes
qui exécute une peine privative de
liberté record depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale la population
carcérale au 1er avril ses 71 milles et
les personnes sous surveillance
électronique
14000 14700 evelyne sire martin si on
prend un peu de recul depuis 20 ans est
ce qu'il ya de plus en plus de détenus
en france plat on a les chiffres de
d'avril mais si on prend une perspective
je m'appelle sire marin oui jeudi martin
j'ai dit marin la première fois et
didier martin l'accusé moi oui alors
depuis 20 ans ce qu'on observe en france
et que les peines ferme d'emprisonnement
ont doublé mais surtout les petites
peines de moins d'un an ça correspond à
30% des peines d'incarcération de prison
et la détention provisoire on oublie
souvent c'est un tiers des personnes qui
sont incarcérés donc ça ce sont des
chiffres je pense il faut attirer
l'attention là dessus est ce que
peut-être qu'ils auraient les moyens de
jouer en quelque sorte sur ces chiffres
pour diminuer le taux d'incarcération
vous l'avez très très bien dit dans
votre reportage
pourquoi en france on n'arrive pas à
faire comme ailleurs en europe en italie
en allemagne aux pays bas bien sûr
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à descendre en
dessous d'un taux très important
d'incarcération alors il ya évidemment
plusieurs plusieurs éléments il a été
très bien dit que la question
psychiatrique est très importante et
j'ai lu un rapport du sénat très
intéressant de 2020 où il disait qu'il y
avait 1 23% de détenus qui souffrait de
problèmes psychiatriques à moi j'avais
lu 30% dans l'eau dans d'autres rapports
mais voyez
si vous avez un tiers des personnes qui
en fait sont pas loin d'être
psychotiques ou tout au moins très
borderline on va on va revenir aux
autres aux autres alternatives et en
amont mais j'ai effectivement ouvrons ce
ce chapitre ii des hôpitaux
psychiatriques ou des prisons destinés à
des détenus qui souffrent de maladies
psychiatriques on est très en retard là
aussi là dessus on est très en retard ja
lire c'est d'abord un problème de
politique de fond oui c'est à dire qu'on
n'a jamais tranché la problématique de
l'eau de la prison dans notre pays on
est toujours dans la logique de
considérer que la seule peine qui compte
c'est la peine de prison et c'est la
peine d'incarcération et tous les soirs
dans tous les journaux français quand on
parle d'un fait c'est qu'elle est le
quantum de la peine il faut doubler la
peine il faut sanctionner plus et on est
là dedans parce qu'on ne comprend pas en
tous les cas on n'explique pas
suffisamment le fait que pour un certain
nombre d'infractions dénature dans la
gravité reste
n'est pas trop grave enfin oui mais est
une sanction mais ne vont un peu aussi
on peut régler le problème sans
forcément mais que la personne rétention
donc mais pour cela encore faut-il
trouver des lieux j'ai par ansa la
semi-liberté en particulier où je pense
aux personnes dans la difficulté
psychiatrie que vous évoquez le chiffre
c'est dur de 30 % dans certains
établissements c'est moche à 40% en
réalité mais les conséquences pour les
gardiens pris en fait tout ça ça
correspond à quoi ça correspond à l'idée
que
on n'a pas les outils en fait une
suffisant pour pouvoir répondre à chaque
type de nature d'infraction jules a
bluffé ça très court en matière
criminelle n'y a pas de problème
globalement le crime l'alpe longues
peines ces traités correctement ça
fonctionne ça marche c'est la détention
provisoire évidemment qu'ils posent
majoritairement un problème puisque là
on est un peu tout le monde dans des
conditions
mon peu et l'exécution de courtes peines
qui est compliqué puisque évidemment
mélange tout le monde reste que si on
avait par exemple si on prenait un
exemple tout simple de quelqu'un qui
commet une infraction la circulation des
récidivistes depuis deux mois fois t'es
pas utile de l'envoyer dans une prison
avec préventive dans un truc impossible
on va peut-être gérer quelque chose en
semi liberté encore faut-il qu il se
sera tout aussi efficace encore faut-il
que on explique les choses à nos
concitoyens qui ne pensent que la
justice pénale en tous les cas la
sanction pénale ce n'est que la prise
effective dans la perception de
l'opinion je vais vous redonner la
parole mais c'est quelque chose
évidemment très important un autre un
autre chiffre qui nous vient du comité
européen pour la prévention de la
torture qui concerne évidemment notre
pays 50 établissements occupé à plus de
150 % de leurs capacités et six
établissements qui dépasse même les 200
% de leurs capacités mathieu quinquis là
quand j'ai commencé à préparer ce débat
je me suis dit la surpopulation
carcérale j'entends ce mot depuis je
crois mon premier stage de journalistes
c'était au quotidien régional sud ouest
en 1987 voyez ça fait 35 ans si mes
calculs sont exacts et on construit de
nouvelles prisons et on est toujours en
train de parler de support surpopulation
carcérale comment vous expliquez ça en
fait l'équation est très simple c'est
que plus on construit plus on remplit et
c'est un principe qui est j'ai envie de
dire vieux comme la justice pénale
moderne je lisais ce matin un livre de
jean fayard qui s'ouvrait par une
citation du ministre de l'intérieur à la
société nationale des prisons en 1830 et
on peut remonter encore plus loin ce
principe là en disant plus on construit
tout le monde plus on remplit et puis on
incarcère et évidemment il faut sortir
de cette logique de construction qui est
une course sans fin sur les trente
dernières années on a construit 24 mille
places de prison pour 4,5 milliards
d'euros il y à 25000 personnes
supplémentaires en détention donc on a
créé de nouvelles places et on a
incarcéré deux nouvelles personnes sans
que le problème de fond effectivement
soit à régler il faut pas oublier que la
prix on dans la loi et ça depuis des
années c'est l'ultime recours et si on
prend chaque dossier qui passe devant
des juridictions on se rend compte qu'il
existe toujours en réalité une
alternative à cet enfermement et qu'on
peut envisager autre chose pour apporter
malgré tout une réponse à une infraction
qui n'est par ailleurs pas contesté et
on y reviendra aux autres alternatives
mais effectivement cette logique de
construire de nouvelles places de prison
c'était aussi celle d' emmanuel macron
un engagement et son garde des sceaux à
eric dupond-moretti rappelait que cet
engagement va être tenues on l'écouté
j'ai signé les terrains j'ai rencontré
les élus je sais que c'est pas simple
parce que vous avez quelques élus qui
vient de se tortiller aux micros des
médias pour dire il faut des prisons des
prisons mais pas chez nous c'est
toujours dans la ville ou dans la
circonscription d'un côté donc il y à
15000 places qui seront sortis de terre
d'ici 2027 et j'ajoute plus encore
notamment magnanville vous le savez et
je veux saluer l'esprit républicain du
maire parce qu'il faut être courageux
quand on est maire d'une commune pour
accepter la création d'un établissement
pénitentiaire
donc on sera plus de 15000 et le
président de la république aura sur
cette question précise des prisons parce
que j'entends souvent que ça fait
polémique parfaitement respecté ses
engagements et bien si romain est ce que
on a besoin de ces places écoutez moi je
trouve ça piquant d'entendre monsieur
dupont moretti notre ministre à nous les
magistrats parce que il avait signé une
lettre ouverte en juin 2020 avec
d'autres associations
demandez la décroissance pénale trouvant
comme avocat bien sûr qu'il y avait
beaucoup trop de personnes en prison
juin 2020 décroissance pénale juillet
2020 nommée garde des sceaux et on a une
loi du 22 décembre
2021 donc un peu plus d'un an après loi
confiance en la justice qui décide qu'on
va désormais réduire la possibilité de
réduction de peine en supprimant les
réductions de peines automatiques je
reviens pas sur l'aspect technique mais
fatalement automatiquement
mathématiquement diminuer la possibilité
de réduction de peine ça veut dire plus
de prisonniers donc c'est quand même
intéressant de voir la différence entre
les projets l'idée et puis ce qu'on en
oeuvre quand on est garde des sceaux
j'entendais marcel gauchet ce matin et
c'était très intéressant et monsieur le
sénateur je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous ces îles il disait à monsieur
cochet et à une absence de vision
globale sur ces questions notamment les
questions de sécurité de prison et
effectivement on a l'impression que le
politique agit en urgence au cas par cas
très soumis à l'opinion publique et que
c'est ça le problème d'un grand plan oui
prison et danses des vents va pas
pouvoir faire l'économie de l'opinion
publique et sa perception cette
thématique est pas quelque chose de
pourri dont j'ai ma publicité mathieu
c'est que quand on voit les politiques
alors quand on tient les propos comme
vous les tenez c'est à dire des propos
chiffres et raisonnée vous êtes aussitôt
pour vous personnellement mais soit
accusé d'angélisme soit accusée d'être
du côté du crime soit d'être aveugle on
a entendu pendant cette campagne
présidentielle quand même donc j'ai
plusieurs candidats ce sera la première
la droite ou même dans la campagne
présidentielle des constructions de
nouvelles places créées suis intéressé
sont opposés à peut-être tous les
candidats il fallait envoyer tout le
monde que c'était un signal envoyé à
l'opinion publique était incapable de
comprendre le raisonnement
tout à fait capable moi je vais vous
donner deux exemples rapide travail
d'intérêt général
on en est à 40 milles ça a quand même un
petit peu augmenté quand on interroge
les français la même opinion publique à
50 % ils sont d'accord et je fais est à
dire pour les peines en dessous de 5 ans
ils disent oui c'est quand même plus
intelligent de faire travailler des gens
plutôt que de les mettre en prison
deuxième exemple on a eu ce monsieur
fillon qui vient d'être condamné bon
certains disent oui mais alors
évidemment il s'en tire encore il va pas
en prison et cetera je trouve que
monsieur fillon il a quand même une
amende de plus d'un million d'euros il a
quand même une amende fiscale en plus
très très importante une inéligibilité
de dix ans et je finis là dessus
monsieur cahuzac l'autre côté du bord
politique il a été condamné à 4 ans
d'emprisonnement avait avec ceux dont
deux avec sursis et donc de ferme pour
une très très grosse fraude fiscale de 4
millions d'euros monsieur cahuzac
au lieu d'aller en prison et bien
pendant deux ans il a été médecin
militaire en guyane est-ce que c'est pas
plus intelligent moi ce que je
souhaiterais ça serait que tout le monde
soit traité comme ça le problème c'est
l'égalité et ça ce serait très très bien
que tout le monde soit traité de cette
manière là l'idée peines alternatives
françois noël buffet effectivement ses
7,7 peut-être facilité je ne sais pas
pour les hommes politiques de dire on va
confirmer de places de prison comment
vous situez par rapport à fin moi je
pense qu'on a besoin d'avoir des places
de prison supplémentaires
d'abord pour régler un problème qui sud
la surpopulation carcérale d'aujourd'hui
d'une part mais on a besoin aussi
d'avoir des lieux privatifs de liberté
de nature différente et notamment de
semi-liberté pour soulager aussi les
gens qui sont en prison ce qui fait
qu'on a un système cohérent mais ce
qu'on ne dit pas c'est que la question
de fond deux concitoyens c'est de dire
on exécute jamais les peines ou c'est
très long en fait on exécute toujours
les peines mais c'est la longueur du
temps pour l'exécuter qui pose problème
donc ce qui compte c'est une réponse
rapide pour avoir une réponse rapide il
vous faut différents lieux privatifs de
liberté qui sont adaptés
il vous faut en même temps un service de
prévention ce qu'on appelle les spip on
a une mission qui est engagée là dessus
la commission des lois en ce moment pour
lequel il ya des moyens qui permettent
de suivre les gens qui ont été condamnés
mais les suivre tout de suite et toi
répondre tout de suite donc en fait
c'est l'ensemble qu'il faut reprendre et
c'est la cohérence de l'ensemble qui
compte donc vous dites malgré tout
quinze mille ou 20000 places
supplémentaires il les faut vous vite
c'est une spirale on en sortait de
nature différente mais de nature
différente évidemment parce que quand on
laisse penser que la construction de
places de prison va permettre de
répondre un problème de délinquance
initial qui traduit qui révèle lui-même
des problèmes sociaux de problèmes
d'insertion de problèmes médicaux de
déracinement par rapport à certains
certaines valeurs sociales qui sont pas
unanimement partagé
en réalité on va droit dans le mur le
problème n'est clairement pas là on peut
exciter à longueur de journée l'opinion
publique à coude fait divers en lui
expliquant qu'il ya des drames sans
cesse plus atroces évidemment évidemment
que face à ces drames il ya des réponses
pénales qui sont importés et on ne peut
pas laisser penser aux personnes qui
nous écoutent que qu'aucune réponse
pénale n'est apportée en revanche on ne
peut pas faire des lois pour répondre à
l'opinion publique on a soi-même excité
et la ou les solutions fonctionnent et
vous avez cité tout à l'heure plusieurs
pays étrangers c'est qu'en réalité il
n'a des études très précises qui
viennent nous dire que c'est en sortant
de cette spirale de construction et de
cette spirale d'enfermement que ça
fonctionne je pense notamment à la
finlande qui a décidé d'axer ses
politiques publiques en matière pénale
et pénitentiaire sur le travail de
chercheur ces travaux il existe aussi en
france et ça fait des années qu'on les
présente aux parlementaires qu'on les
présente nous avocats aux magistrats
dans les salles d'audience pour les
convaincre que la prison n'est pas la
solution alors jusqu'à l'essai
au delà du fait que je ne partage pas
tout à fait le côté doctrinaire que vous
évoquez ce que je ne pense pas te dire
un discours qui soit un discours
absolument scandaleux sur le fait
d'avoir besoin de lieux privatifs de
liberté dès lors qu'ils sont
diversifiées pas ce qui m'intéresse et
doit revenir devant le juge paradis
robot jubin voilà le cas de mon client
et qu'ils aient les outils office il lui
permettant de pouvoir donner une réponse
rapide et efficace la majorité du temps
les magistrats qui sont à l'audience
qu'est ce qu'ils disent déçus donne une
peine
qui n'est pas prêt hâtif de liberté
gérard des problèmes d'exécution le jab
alco manqué trop tard et finalement ça a
mal se passer c'est ça en réalité la
boîte à outils étaient insuffisantes
elle est insuffisante non pas sur les
éléments de droit la capacité à fait
mais sur la capacité à faire dire qu'on
a besoin de moyens budgétaires c'est un
peu basique même chose 4,5 milliards
c'est pas parce que l'on consacré à la
construction dépresseurs l'aimé
dernières années mettez ces 4,5
milliards du jour entre les mains des
magistrats je pense en fait rimer
médiane entre les deuxièmes de leur
assurer de preuves et de probation tout
médiane mais
c'est finalement la moitié de la sq il
hier la rénovation faut pas oublier non
plus incertain un certain nombre de deux
maisons d'arrêt qui était dans un état
déplorable moi aussi quelques-unes ont
rejoint d'ailleurs que la rénovation
alors je reprends la main pour faire un
jeter un oeil à ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays d'europe grâce à steve
jours d'un rebond soir steve là où se
situe la france en matière de population
carcérale par rapport à nos voisins
mauvais élèves ce qui est clair c'est
que la france est à contre-courant de
toutes les tendances européennes pour
avoir une idée il faut consulter les
space les space l'espace je sais pas
comment on dit les statistiques pénales
annuelle du conseil de l'europe le
dernier rapport en date est celui de
2021 on y apprend que le nombre de
détenus pour 100000 habitants a continué
de baisser légèrement en europe en 2006
une tendance hourdin qui a commencé il
ya huit ans 2000 en 2001 une tendance
qui a commencé il ya une dizaine
d'années cette tendance à la baisse mais
quand on regarde dans le détail on se
rend compte que sur la décennie entre
2010 et 2020 la france avance à reculons
en france ce taux d'incarcération est
passé de 100,3 personnes détenues pour
100000 habitants à 105,3 c'est une
hausse de 1,7 sur dix ans dans le même
temps ce taux est bien diminue en italie
et en allemagne sur la même période il
est passé de 88 à 76 en allemagne et 216
à 101 en italie en résumé eh bien la
france se trouve dans le top 10 top 10
ans sur 49 pays top 10 des pays ayant
connu la plus forte croissance de sa
population
en une décennie est ce que ça veut dire
pour autant que la france est le pays
qui a la plus grande population
carcérale en europe n'ont pas forcément
parce que là encore il faut regarder le
taux d'incarcération le nom de détenus
encore pour 100000 habitants se rend
compte que deux de nos voisins nous
battent en la matière il s'agit du
royaume uni et de l'espagne au royaume
uni ces 138 détenus pour 100000
habitants l'espagne 123 détenus pour
cent mille habitants il s'agit de deux
pays qui ont des politiques pénales très
répressive historiquement très répressif
vous voulez encore vous comparez pour
voir assuré thomas vous pouvez regarder
aussi la turquie la turquie qui fait
partie du conseil de l'europe sur kylie
à 357 8 personnes détenues pour 100000
habitants ça un record à l'échelle du
conseil de l'europe parce que vous êtes
rassurés pas vraiment non encore en
passer à une comparaison qui est
peut-être moins flatteuse je peux vous
dire maintenant qu'en matière de
surpopulation carcérale la france n'est
pas très loin justement derrière la
turquie on est dans le top 5 au niveau
européen en matière de densité carcérale
non ce top ça qu'il ya donc la turquie
il y à l'italie la belgique chypre et
donc la france en france on compte 115 7
détenues pour 100 places de détention la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
nous a condamné à plusieurs reprises les
conditions de détention en france sont
contraires au droit aux droits de
l'homme selon les juges européens merci
steve evelyne sire-marin si on regarde
ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays comme
pas parce que l'on voit vraiment à la
fois le décalage et puis surtout des
tendances qui sont inverse chez nous
voisins en matière de population
carcérale
comment ça se passe par exemple aux pays
bas c'est quoi les alternatives qui
fonctionne là bas alors il ya plusieurs
exemples les pays bas ce qui marche très
bien comme alternative c'est ce qu'on
appellerait nous le travail d'intérêt
général la semi liberté
bon il faut quand même dire qu'en france
le problème c'est qu'à la différence du
des pays bas et surtout le canada par
exemple un conseiller d'insertion et de
probation c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
suit une personne pour l'aider à la ré
insérer sans qu'on la mette en prison en
essayant quel travail en essayant
qu'elle se soigne et bien en france une
personne comme ça elle va avoir 60
dossiers au moins à suivre par exemple
au canada elle aura vendent aussi à ce
fils dont elle peut beaucoup plus
s'occuper il ya quelque chose qui est
pas mal du tout qui vient de se mettre
en place pour proposer aux juges des
peines alternatives à l'incarcération ça
s'appelle la plateforme tiges travail
d'intérêt général 360° et ça c'est pas
mal du tout parce que ça permet et ça
marche bien d'aller à l'audience quand
on est avocat quand on est éducateur
quand on a des mineurs que les jeux je
veux le mettre en prison et bien là on
va consulter cette plate forme et on va
dire là il ya une place de travail
d'intérêt général pour faire de l'espace
vert pour faire la manutention etc
plutôt que le mettre en prison moi je
vous dis il pourrait faire ce travail
d'intérêt général et là le juge il a
quelque chose de concret qui lui est
proposé voyez et pour finir sur l'europe
sur l'europe c'est vrai que nous on est
très forts en matière de détention
provisoire je les dis un tiers des
peines mais ça c'est pas du tout le cas
des autres pays pas du tout l'allemagne
a baissé de 22% son nombre de détention
provisoire et il ya autre chose c'est ce
qu'on appelle les comparutions
immédiates ce qui s'appelait les
flagrants délits ça c'est pour voyeurs
énormément de peines fermes et je
regarde
dès les rapports sur l'europe en fait
les autres pays d'europe ils n'ont pas
ils ont des procédures de comparution
immédiate de jugement rapide comme nous
mais c'est pas comme ça dans les 48
heures ce que ce soit en allemagne où il
ya beaucoup moins de détenus en italie
ou au portugal où il ya beaucoup moins
de détenus comme par hasard les
procédures accélérées si vous voulez
c'est sûr s'est accélérée mais il ya 30
jours et à six semaines avant de juger
la personne donc on a le temps d'étudier
la personnalité de donner des éléments
de personnalité avant et ça c'est une
grosse différence mais ils sont pas en
détention provisoire alors sont là en
attendant évidemment ils sont pas
nécessairement en détention provisoire
nous non plus en comparution immédiate
mais très souvent comment battre mais
les procédures normales sont peut-être
plus rapide en allemagne qu'en france
alors en allemagne csu a fait changer
une question sur l'allemagne parce que
on s'implique avec une culture d'ordre
on va dire est ce que dans le débat
public pour rendre ma cliente leur est
ce que c'est vu comme du laxisme est ce
que c'est vu comme de l'angélisme est ce
que on se jette ses noms d'oiseaux entre
hommes politiques est ce que on a les
mêmes stigmates voyage dans le débat
public en france non non je crois pas
sincèrement je crois pas il faut aller
visiter une maison d'arrêt en allemagne
c'est comment c'est à l'allemande comme
vous recommander c'est très organisés
c'est très réfléchie et mais c'est
vraiment très réfléchi en termes de
fonctionnalités moi j'ai été fortement
surpris de voir que en france on a des
pavillons où les cellules se regarde
entre elles les gens s'invectivent d'un
d'un d'un pavillon à l'autre se jetter
téléphones vont on connaît ça en
allemagne ils ont mis des bureaux des
côtés des cellules de l'autre bâtiment
ce qui fait que vous avez une forme
d'apaisement qui est assez grand c'est
évidemment impeccable mais surtout ils
n'ont pas de surpopulation carcérale de
l'encellulement elle est individuelle au
maximum à 2 donc ils sont très très
structuré et très très organisé on
aurait tout intérêt à
tenir compte de la manière dont il
travaille je trouve ça très intéressant
on ne fait pas assez de comparaison avec
les autres pays en réalité on est sur un
système
qui est toujours le même et ça c'est
vraiment dommage et je crois que sur ce
que vous dites vous avez raison sur
la question de la plateforme 360 qui est
récente et d'ailleurs qui fonctionnent
assez bien mais la procédure des
flagrants délits pour aller dans
plusieurs tribunaux sur le territoire
national je me suis rendue compte
qu'elle servait de plus en plus
d'alternatives à la procédure normale
parce que ça soulage et les audiences
quant à l'époque où je l'aidais
l'audience de comparution immédiate elle
avait lieu en début d'audience normal on
prenait les deux ou les trois premiers
dossiers y passer en premier et puis
après on prenait l'audience normale aux
fonds classiques aujourd'hui il consacre
d après midi entière uniquement à des
audiences de comparution immédiate c'est
à dire qu'on débute à 80 en 30 ou à 13h
à 13h30 au karabagh pardon mais on finit
à 22 heures 23 au 24 e lle donc on
regarde
alors que le budget de la justice ils
augmentent effectivement
augmenté mais il faut pas dans
l'augmentation du budget de justice qui
est des 2% quand cette année il ya une
partie qui par la pénitentiaire pour des
rattrapages il ya une partie qui
normalement consacré au numérique quand
on voit pas tellement avancer les choses
et le et le reste est un peu un peu
bloquée donc on peut pas faire trop de
généralités il faut bien regarder en
détail comment ça marche moi je reste
intimement convaincu que si on veut
qu'on ait une justice qui fonctionne
c'est d'abord une question de moyens
humains et de questions de moyens
techniques et ensuite à droit constant
c'est à dire sans aller faire la
révolution de partout je pense que si on
a un effort très fort là dessus on
arrive à sortir de la difficulté dans
laquelle nous sommes les états généraux
de la justice qui est de soutenir le
rapport est pas encore public qui n'est
pas encore rendu on verra dans les
quelques jours ou quelques semaines qui
viennent mais pour ma part c'est d'abord
un moyen humain des moyens humains et
des moyens techniques qu'il faut et je
reprends l'exemple des pays-bas si je ne
me trompe ya une période où il louait
leur prison vide à la belgique et à la
norvège alors je pense qu'elles ont
fermé depuis six jeux si j'ai trouvé les
bonnes infos mathieu quinquis mais ils
n'ont pas forcément moins de délinquance
ou alors ils ont moins de délinquance
parce que leur politique par exemple
pénale en matière de drogue n'est pas la
même qu'en france c'est est ce que c'est
une part de l'explication les leviers
sont effectivement multiples et la
question de ce qu'on pénalise et de ce
qu'on incrimine doit aussi se poser en
france est aujourd'hui on n'envisage pas
suffisamment c'est ce levier là pour
essayer de réduire à la fois le nombre
de passages en prison mais aussi le
nombre de passages devant la justice y
ait un certain nombre d'infractions qui
ne méritent pas en tant que tel de faire
l'objet d'une telle procédure
extrêmement lourde
mon propos n'est pas de dire qu'il faut
des procédures alternatives aux
poursuites avec des pouvoirs
supplémentaires aux procureurs mais
simplement qu'un moment où se pose qu'on
se calme qu'on réfléchisse à ce qu'on
décide de sanctionner collectivement et
on va voir que le code pénal regorge un
ensemble d'infraction parfaitement
inutile mais qui sont pourvoyeurs
d'incarcération et notamment en
comparution immédiate par l'usaf de
stupéfiants usage de stups et délits
routiers sans qu'il y ait de blessure le
délit routier bon c'est très mal de
conduire en état d'ivresse a doit être
puni il ya pas de problème est ce que ça
pourrait pas être punis de façon
administrative ce que ça suffirait pas
de suspendre le permis de conduire par
le préfet c'est exactement la même chose
que ce que quand il ya pas de blessures
corporelles il y avait deux blessures
corporelles bien sûr ouais et alors moi
je pars donc je rebondis sur la drogue
est ce que la dépénalisation de la
drogue c'est une partie de l'équation
pour vous sur le visage oui il faut une
politique de santé publique mais non
mais c'est un louvre à notre débat on a
déjà eu ici mais lui c'est vraiment pas
content j'ai pas là aussi je n'ai pas
trouvé quelle est la part de deux
détenus de détenus qui sont en prison
aujourd'hui peut-être pour les courtes
peines zige a lié à ces questions de
70000 condamnation donation trafic de
drogue 70000 condamnation pour sup la
moitié pour usage déjà
on aurait ces condamnations en moins si
on traitait peut-être pas en
dépénalisant mais au moins en
transformant en amendes la même chose en
amendes administratives en en amendes
déjà le visage d'usagé de stupéfiants
s'est puni de dix ans d'emprisonnement
quel est le sens de cette infraction
mais est-ce que c'est appliquer
strictement aucun mais la question n'est
pas est ce qu'elle est c'est appliquer
concrètement c est ce que ça peut être
appliquée aujourd'hui si un magistrat
veut prononcer dix ans pour usage de
stupéfiants il peut le faire et donc en
réalité il ya la part du législateur
dans la question de la sueur
incarcération est un suroccupation des
établissements et ya la part du juge
tant que le législateur laissera des
deux des leviers et des possibilités au
juge pour qu'il prononce des peines
d'emprisonnement de manière parfois
disproportionnées de manière injustifiée
de manière démesurée eh bien on
continuera d'avoir ce problème donc il
faut prendre le sujet globalement se
poser sur la question de la
dépénalisation et ensuite voir comment
on peut effectivement orienter les juges
vers d'autres types de sanctions le
l'emprisonnement alors ce qui est
passionnant ce débat mais j'ai en tête
depuis plusieurs minutes le discours que
tiennent depuis des années des policiers
de terrain des policiers de la bac
j'entends d'un policier de la bac nord
il ya quelques semaines sur rtl ou alors
des syndicalistes sur le supposé laxisme
des juges
écoutons jérôme moisan c'était ici ils
étaient entendus lors d'une audition
c'était au sénat secrétaire national aux
conditions de travail oit syndicat unité
sgp police
hulot va nous on reste ici avec
l'évolution de la justice a là où il a
trop en
aménagement de peine était l'exception
et
isolement était la règle pour les délits
ou crimes l on réalise se maintenant en
fonctionnement et de l'échelle sont l
aménagement de belles heil il faut
vraiment qu'on revienne à quelque chose
de plus efficients à l'onf un bon ça la
sanction pénale a vocation à unir à
réparer et cerise sur le gâteau tour à
réinsérer et le sauteur de l'infraction
est le constat qu'on fait c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle a soudain on pioche et
aucune ne sais pas evelyne sire-marin
vous dites que c'est quoi un cliché ou
alien part de vérité comment réagissez
vous savez le corps des policiers en
tout cas les policiers les policiers tu
es un être très très syndiqués 1 c'est
le corps le plus indiqué bon non mais ça
veut dire que les syndicats ils ont
quand même aussi les syndicats de police
ils ont un discours qui est adapté à
la préservation de leur existence aussi
les policiers de terrain c'est pas du
tout la même chose que les commissaires
de police vous nous auriez montré un
commissaire de police ils ont pas le
même discours un procureur qui en
principe est quelqu'un qui a choisi ce
métier plus tôt pour demander des pelles
c'est pas le même discours ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous avez dit vous
même il ya 86 mille paires personnes qui
sont en détention sous bracelet
il y en a onze mille et puis tout le
reste c'est en incarcération en cellule
il ya 180 mille peines alternatives
et comme disait monsieur le sénateur est
ce que c'est un problème que quelqu'un
soit en semi liberté c'est délire
dorment la nuit en prison je travaille
le jour où phase d'être face des stages
c'est j'entends vraiment j'entends
vraiment vos arguments mais je reprends
le discours est alors là sont des
policiers de terrain policiers de la bac
bac nord à marseille qui est alors ça
fait là aussi des années qu'on entend ça
les délinquant trafic de drogue on les
arrête on les revoit et nous narguent et
un jour après bon qu'est ce que vous
répondez les usagers eh bien c'était pas
un policier s'indigne on s'est insurgé
peut-être mais alors en matière de
trafic de stupéfiants on a des peines
alors à paris très couramment à
marseille c'est pareil de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement qui sont prononcés de 7
ans de 10 ans c'est par la 16e chambre
correctionnelle c'est des peines
extrêmement lourdes mais le problème
aussi c'est que moi j'ai observé sur le
terrain que souvent les policiers de
terrain n'était pas informée en fait de
ce qui se passait au niveau de la
justice s'en fout et ça c'est peut-être
ça serait peut-être bien d'améliorer ça
on n'a pas nous les magistrats à leur
rendre compte c'est normalement le
contraire les policiers normalement sont
sous la tutelle de la justice mais ça
serait bien qu'ils soient informés parce
que à partir du moment où la personne
sort du tribunal le policier m'a dit
robin il a rien eu mais attendez il a
peut-être eu il a peut-être un travail
d'intérêt général qui peut aller jusqu'à
400 quand même affaire il a peut-être eu
ou une semi-liberté ou un bracelet
électronique mais pour le policier il a
rien eu et ça je pense qu'il ya vraiment
un manque d'information ou peut-être une
volonté un petit peu de dresser les
policiers contre les juges ce qui est
pas une bonne chose dans une démocrate
françois noël buffet y aille on a
l'impression de alors que vous
travaillez ensemble de deux univers qui
ont effectivement un mal fou à se parler
univers des policiers et celui des des
magistrats
il exagère oui parce que quand on
discute avec les procureurs de la
république
ils sont en lien constant avec les
policiers qui mène les enquêtes qui
mènent des actions ils se voient
régulièrement et sincèrement sur le
terrain je crois pouvoir témoigner
qu'ils s'apprécient ça fonctionne donc
il ya effectivement un aspect qui est
réel qui est un peu un aspect
corporatif c'est possible
pourquoi pas inviter fait son travail
mais sur le terrain ça fonctionne pas
comme ça mais enfin en revanche il est
vrai que les policiers sont confrontés
de plus en plus à des situations d'une
extrême violence ça on peut pas le
contester c'est la vérité donc ce qui
compte c'est la réponse pénale quelle
que soit la nature de celles-ci qui doit
avoir un caractère immédiat une
effectivité la plus rapide possible si
on veut avoir un effet si on veut que ça
marche c'est ce qui nous manque le plus
en revanche un dernier pointe sur la le
quantum des peines
si on regarde on fait le bilan sur
plusieurs années en arrière
les sanctions sont de plus en plus
élevés et de plus en plus à leurs
importants le chiffre je vais dans
l'autre sens source conseil de l'europe
le mois de janvier 2020 la durée moyenne
d'un quart ses rations en france ces
onze ans et un mois et en allemagne
c'est moins de cinq ans c'est ça mais
juste partage l'avis de monsieur tout à
l'heure sur l'idée qu' il ya un moment
il faut faire des choix de stratégies
pénale est de savoir ce que l'on
sanctionne ce que l'on poursuit ce que
l'on ne poursuit pas donc on poursuit
par j'ai pas dire ça comme ça parce que
c'est pas juste mais ce que l'on
poursuit de manière différente la
procédure qu'on adapte parce qu'on ne
peut pas tout gérer à l'audience est
renvoyée tout le monde à l'audience ça
n'a pas de sens c'est très compliqué à
faire donc ça veut dire que les fictions
sur le fond il faut repenser le
fonctionnement de la justice pénale mais
vous ne pouvez pas repenser le
fonctionnement de tus pénale en ayant
que simplement la vision de l'audience
la vision de l'exécution de la peine
pour moi est fondamental c'est une
exécution je le redis et pas forcément
privative de liberté elle peut l'être
elle peut être de nature différente la
semi liberté mais la question de
l'exécution pour les petites les
comporte des petit à petit ce qu'on
appelle la petite délinquance doit être
bien mais bien plus renforcée sur voxna
et monsieur le sénateur la la la
complexité la subtilité dans votre
famille politique on l'entend
pratiquement jamais en compte notamment
les lecteurs c'est un tort
c'est un tort
c'est un tort je veux dire on
il faut regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont et fixer des stratégies de
fonds qui soit compréhensible par
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens faut faire
un peu confiance aux gens à partir du
moment où on est cohérent et on se donne
les moyens de faire parce que la vraie
question c'est des moyens de faire une
fois qu'on se donne les moyens de faire
quand la souffrance ça marche mais cela
dit il ya aucun ministre quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs récemment comme il ya un peu
plus longtemps qu'ils aient pris
globalement l'ensemble des dispositifs
en main c'est un travail très très fort
très puissant qu'il faut mener mais il
faut d'abord affiché une vision de ce
qu'on veut et la vision de la justice
s'est d'ailleurs pas seulement la vision
pénale la maison civile en mobile mais
c'est plus de deux millions huit cent
mille décisions par an c'est quelque
chose d'encore plus important dans les
françaises souffrent également de façon
très importante mais sur le plan pénal
je n'ai pas une stratégie globale moi
c'est ce que j'appelle communément
certains n'aiment pas la chaîne pénale
mais la chaîne pénale c'est la police la
justice la pénitentiaire avec
l'exécution des peines si vous n'avez si
vous avez dans ce ce triptyque un
maillon faible eh ben c'est toute la
chaîne qui est fait mal donc c'est bien
l'ensemble qu'il faut voir et puis il
faut jamais oublier que votre objectif
commun est quand même de protéger la
société est ce que cette situation
mathieu quinquis de surpopulation
carcérale finalement ça n'empêche pas la
prison de jouer son rôle c'est à dire de
réinsertion est ce qu'il ya plus est ce
qu'on peut faire le lien entre la
surpopulation carcérale carcérale est
par exemple le taux de récidive
évidemment évidemment parce que la
surpopulation population carcérale c'est
la négation des droits et donc on va
demander à une personne de se réinsérer
dans la société de respecter le droit la
manière dont on a décidé de vivre
ensemble en lui imposant une situation
qui est contraire au droit justement on
a fixé donc évidemment sur le plan des
principes il ya déjà une première
difficulté mais ensuite très
concrètement il ya aussi une difficulté
c'est que les établissements ils sont
organisés sur l'or sur leur capacité
théorique sur le nombre de places qui
existe normalement c'est à dire que le
nombre de surveillants qui sont affectés
dans cet établissement correspond au
nombre de places théoriques pas au
nombre de places réellement occupé il en
est de même pour les médecins dans est
de même pour les infirmiers il en est de
même pour les services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation et donc en
réalité on est face à des services qui
sont pas du tout calibré pour
accompagner les personnes détenues et
qui donc se retrouve complètement
submergé qui sont obligés de prioriser
certains profils et qui en laisse
d'autres qui contribuent à la
marginalisation évidente de ces
personnes tant sur le plan des droits
que sur le plan suit sociale familiale
et puis après il ya d un ensemble de
questions qu'il faut aussi se poser sur
la nature des établissements construits
ou est ce qu on les construit puisque à
priori le parlement s'accordent pour
dire qu'il faut construire des prisons
où est ce qu'on construit ses prisons
c'est intéressant de voir la liste qui
est proposée par eric dupond moretti
mais ce sont des établissements qui sont
souvent éloignés des centres urbains
c'est à dire éloigné des pôles
d'activité éloigné des services publics
et donc ce sont des personnes détenues
qui vont ensuite se retrouver privés
d'un certain nombre de ses services et
des familles qui ne vont pas pouvoir
accéder correctement aux établissements
pour maintenir le lien qu'elles ont avec
elle alors qu'on sait que c'est
justement ces liens là et la
correspondance avec la vie extérieure
qui est un facteur de réinsertion est un
facteur de sortie de la délinquance est
enfin terminée là dessus merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir accès à ce débat